What do you think of reverse osmosis water?
Well, personally, we have reverse osmosis water at our clinic.
Our clinic is out in the country, but we have a lot of nitrates in the water,
so we do get a reverse osmosis unit because that will take those out.
At my home, we live in the country, and we have a well also.
We do not have a reverse osmosis unit because we haven't had our water tested,
and it's like, great. So I want the nutrients that are in the water too,
so I don't have a reverse osmosis.
But if I every time I didn't live in the city where we had chlorade and fluoride,
we had a reverse osmosis unit.
A lot of people say, oh, that's not good because you know your water's dead.
I'm sorry, but you know, I'm not drinking my water to get minerals from my water.
I'm drinking my water for the water.
So I'm getting minerals for my food.
So I don't buy that argument.
I think reverse osmosis is the best way to take out, you know, other things and chemicals that, you know,
and just a simple carbon filter won't take out.
Carbon will take out a lot of the fluoride and a lot of the chlorine,
but it's not going to take out the nitrates.
It's not going to take out any like heavy metals or mercury or arsenic and things that are commonly in water.
So I am a fan of reverse osmosis.